welcome to hannity and tonight we are
tracking multiple
major breaking stories including history
made at the white house with a
groundbreaking peace accord between
israel the uae
and bahrain president trump is calling
it the dawn
of a new middle east media mob democrats
predictably noticeably upset apparently
their hatred of all things trump is
clearly more important than world peace
especially in the middle east
we'll explain all this coming up tonight
plus hannity 2020 election
correspondents our own lawrence jones
in florida on the ground outside of a
biden event
where trump supporters turned out in
full force to give joe a warm welcome
and also yesterday in a truly unhinged
speech
well biden predicted that man-made
climate change and fossil fuels that he
will eliminate
would soon destroy the world and today
a well he boarded a massive private jet
of course a lot of carbon emissions for
a short one-day trip down to florida
and joe biden's america the rules only
apply to we the people you
not him but hey maybe we should give joe
the benefit of the doubt
maybe just maybe maybe he forgot all
about yesterday's insane
climate change speech and he's so
obviously having uh cognitive issues
that's being polite
after all he's having more and more
trouble recalling basal basic facts what
day of the week it is what office he's
running for
uh whether he's going for re-election or
election you know for example his
running mate
by the way kamala harris uh yeah
i think it's the harris biden ticket now
take a look it says daily troop updates
u.s troops died in iran and afghanistan
harris biden administration is going to
relaunch that effort if you could
take care if you were a quartermaster
you can sure in health take care of
running a you know department store uh
thing
you know where in the second floor of
the ladies department or whatever you
know what i mean
no i don't know what you mean in case
you're keeping track joe mixed up
iran and iraq yet again he went on a
bizarre
rant about a quarter master in
department stores
and someone should really start
reminding joe that he's
not running for vice president under the
harris biden ticket
even though his running mate is already
plotting
harris administration take a look
a harris administration together with
joe
biden as the president of the united
states the biden harris administration
will
have access provide access to 100
billion dollars in low-interest loans
so just 49 days until you become the
ultimate jury in election day
do you trust joe and kamala harris
let me ask you this question would you
hire joe to manage
and run even a busy mcdonald's
restaurant that's a hard job
you know a lot of orders you got to race
around let's let me see
french fries quarter pounder let me go
back and look gonna
what was it again quarter pounder with
cheese hang on
i don't know biden can barely leave his
basement without having a full-on public
meltdown
we're constantly refusing to take
questions from even his adoring fans in
the media mob
and all four you know all these events
he does are all scripted
complete with his trusty teleprompter in
an interview today
biden's campaign manager seemingly
confirming her candidate's dependence on
the teleprompter
but she also lied and said that he takes
questions from reporters every day
no that's a lie take a look how do you
respond to the criticism that has
uh we've seen this all over about the
vice president using a teleprompter
during some of these interviews
oh well i mean first of all i i would
say very clearly the vice president uses
a teleprompter
on occasion you see it as giving a
speech but he is also out there every
day
taking questions from reporters no he's
not
in truth in reality joe biden doesn't
take questions from reporters
because he doesn't seem too capable of
speaking freely without saying
move it up move it up uh yeah yeah to
answer a simple question
that'll make it a fool of himself two
weeks from tonight we'll have the very
first debate
in 49 days you the american people will
be the ultimate jury
you will decide the fate of this great
country i cannot confidently predict
tonight what will happen and nobody else
can either
but let me put it like this the election
i use the analogy of a football game
two minutes left in the game fourth
quarter no timeouts
it's a two minute drill you're on your
own 20. you need to march down the field
80 yards you need to cross the plane
hit the extra point to win it won't be
easy it never is for a republican
nothing is certain
but if you care enough about this
country and liberty and freedom and
capitalism and energy independence and
better trade deals
and peace through strength and not
appeasement and hard work and risk and
reward and
invention and innovation yeah a lot on
the ballot in 49 days
we ultimately will get the government we
do deserve though won't we